[Music]  you said you're the happiest you've ever  been right now  you've been happy in your life and your  relationship what are the keys to having  a happy relationship in Hollywood I  think the key is to remember that it is  just like every other relationship and  if you're in Hollywood or if you're in  if you're in you know Africa it's all  the same just love and to be loved  and lastly crown bed kill it's our  version of shag marry kill we've got  Khaleesi Jon Snow and unser sea crown  feds kill I was crown sassy no I can't  kill any of these people okay I'd kill  ceci because you know just kind of a I  do I'd crown John because I think he has  such integrity and it's such a wonderful  person with a really good heart and I  would bed is it Damaris yeah Khaleesi  because she is so x I'd love to see that  you